we could see our third tropical storm of
the year later today even though
hurricane season started just yesterday
as if the country wasn't coping with
enough already scientists believe we may
have three to six major hurricanes this
season the corona virus is complicating
nearly every aspect of disaster planning
Manuel Bojorquez shows us how emergency
officials in Miami are trying to prepare
when hurricane / South Florida in 2017
emergency managers did what they always
do evacuated thousands on buses housing
them enlarged and sometimes crowded
shelters this year will be different we
will screen people when they come take
their temperature ask them the standard
questions if they have any symptoms and
we'll ask them if they have been
cohabitating with somebody that has
covered 19 frank Rallis in miami-dade
counties director of Emergency
Management says kovat cases will need to
be isolated and the county may use
hotels government buildings even empty
classrooms but he worries that the
current social distancing messaging
fights the evacuation messaging we've
been telling them for so long now that
you're safer at home don't congregate
stay away from each other but now you're
going to be safer with us for a
hurricane so your concern people would
be afraid to go to a shelter because of
the virus and endanger themselves to the
storm right that's that's a concern that
we have meanwhile Florida Power and
Light is doing its usual storm prep
normally when the power goes out an army
of power workers from dozens of states
rides to the rescue but travel and
health restrictions are already creating
issues as Michael djaro
and FPL vice-president we've noticed
actually early on this year several
utilities have been challenged trying to
get additional resources in order for
them to restore service it will be
harder for you to restore power
absolutely we anticipate there to be
extended restaurant
sometimes if we were challenged with
hurricane this year amid a global
pandemic Florida's governor has urged
the states more than 20 million
residents to stock up now if you need
flashlights if you need batteries if you
need generators that's a tall order for
the unemployed more than 2 million
Floridians have filed unemployment
claims since mid-march like Janet Simon
it's a punch in the gut because I have
no money to prepare
I have nothing I'm basically trying to
survive and buying a little bit here
with three kids and an unemployed
husband Simon is finally getting some
hours at her restaurant jobs so when it
comes to hurricane season do you feel
even more vulnerable this year
absolutely
these storms are getting stronger and
stronger from what they're saying that
we can expect we're definitely not
prepared at all a recent survey by
triple-a mirrors some of the concerns
officials have about hurricanes during
the pandemic nearly a third of people
who responded said they are more
concerned about this hurricane season
over the last but 42% said fear of the
virus would make them less likely to
evacuate ahead of a major storm Anthony
yeah I know Thank You Manuel and again
scientists say 3 to 6 hurricanes could
come this season